[musique]
Marions-nous ou allons à Disney ensemble.
Je ne suis jamais allé à Disney auparavant, alors je suis allé avec toi.
Des choses comme aller à Disney ne se sont pas réalisées.
est
Mais je ne peux vraiment pas vivre sans toi
Il n'y a que toi
On le dit depuis longtemps
[musique]
Hé
Je suis doué pour l'écoute et je peux parler de tout.
C'est probablement là.
L'hôte qui a profité de moi ne sortira plus manger après ça.
Ce qu'on appelle le service après-vente, mais je fais habituellement du service après-vente.
Comme si je pouvais y aller si c'était pour toi
Je n'ai pas mangé comme on me l'avait dit, alors je suppose que je vais y aller.
Je n'arrive pas à croire que je puisse manger du riz pour 1 000 yens.
Je pensais que ce n'était pas bon et je l'ai dit.
On m'a présenté un travail, mais c'était une rencontre.
Je me sens seul et je n'ai aucun endroit où appartenir.
utiliser pour
Je ne pense pas qu'il les laissait partir.
[musique]
Bien sûr, avec ce syndrome Kabuki,
Nous avons également collaboré avec le maire de Shinjuku.
Maintenant que je suis là pour te parler, c'est moi.
Bien qu’elles se développent naturellement, les nouvelles règles sont fermement mises en place.
Je pense le protéger.
[musique]
Cela signifie qu'il a atteint le fond.
Laissez-moi commencer sans
Masu
Donc, cette fois aussi, nous continuerons à l’organiser à l’avenir.
En y allant, nous nous retrouverons cette fois.
En établissant diverses règles volontaires
Naturellement, un environnement dans lequel il est difficile de faire des affaires est né.
Comment pouvons-nous tous surmonter cela ?
Il y a également des discussions au sein de l’association sur la marche à suivre.
Les dirigeants ont parlé
[musique]
et
différence